All right, I'm going to talk about emerging therapies and CMML, which has kind of been
long overlooked.
And we'll kind of first go over the DAKOTA trial.
So I'm sure many of you are familiar with the DAKOTA trial.
It was the first randomized phase three trial specifically for CMML.
This trial enrolled patients with myeloproliferative CMML, which is defined as patients who had
a white blood cell count over 13,000.
And they had to have either extramedullary disease or two or more criteria amongst those
that are listed kind of indicating higher risk disease.
They were randomized one-to-one to either hydroxyurea or to dacitabine.
And the primary endpoint of the DAKOTA trial was event-free survival, which was defined
as death, second transformation to secondary AML or CMML.
And so, again, I'm sure many of you are familiar with the results of the DAKOTA trial, which
basically showed no difference in terms of EFS or OS between hydroxyurea and dacitabine.
However, there was a signal of increased progression or AML transformation in the hydroxyurea
arm compared to the dacitabine arm.
However, this was sort of outweighed by early toxicity in the dacitabine arm.
So it ended up that there was no real survival benefit seen.
So, again, this is kind of the takeaway from the DAKOTA study.
There were superior response rates with dacitabine, but toxicity may have masked a survival benefit.
So kind of interestingly, this was just published in Leukemia.
Showing that there is a role, perhaps, for cytoreduction in proliferative CMML.
So this is a post hoc analysis from the DAKOTA trial.
And basically, what the authors showed was that if you look at the patient's blood counts
at cycle six, these are the blood counts from the patients enrolled in the DAKOTA trial at
cycle six, if they had an absolute monocyte count less than 1,000 and a white blood cell count less
than 10,000, they actually had superior overall survival compared to those who had elevated absolute
monocyte counts or white blood cell count over 10,000, and this was regardless of treatment.
So this is interesting data basically telling us that there may be a survival benefit associated
with cytoreduction of monocytes and immature granulocytes in CMML that is treatment independent.
So very similar to the paradigm in the classical
MPNs where you have cytoreduction and you are able to kind of modulate survival to an extent.
And there was also shown to be an improvement in overall survival and also
decreased transformation to AML at the cycle three, after cycle three, if patients had
lower classical monocyte counts or lower immature granulocyte counts after cycle
C, after cycle three. So again, suggesting that cytoreduction could be important in CMML
and improve survival irrespective of how you cytoreduce patients.
Okay. So this is data from ASH 2025. This is another randomized trial,
this time in MDS MPN. So this included CMML patients, but also patients with any of the other
MDS MPNs, excluding GMML. So this is an adult trial. And so in this trial, which is the MOUK
trial, they're randomizing patients two to one to Roldesidabine versus Hydroxyurea. And the
enrollment criteria are not quite exactly the same as in Dakota, but you're kind of trying to
select for patients who have a more proliferative phenotype or higher risk disease. And so this is a
trial design. These patients are treated for six cycles with either Roldesidabine versus
Hydroxyurea and then assessed for a response. So primary endpoint is
best response at cycle six using the MDS MPN criteria from 2015.
And so responses are kind of defined as clinical benefit or better. And so this is actually the
first trial to show an improvement in overall survival in MDS MPN. So this trial, the MOUK trial,
does show an improvement in overall survival with Roldesidabine, 24.2 months compared to
Hydroxyurea, 17 months. And the response rates were about twice as high with Roldesidabine
compared to Hydroxyurea as well. And so if you look at the CMML subgroups,
specifically, you also see the same trends. You see improved overall survival, progression-free
survival, and AML-free survival with Roldesidabine versus Hydroxyurea. So
this is something I would consider an evolving standard of care for CMML.
Most of the patients in Dakota and this trial did require dose reductions. As
some of you probably know, Roldesidabine can be quite myelosuppressive. But again,
this is the first trial that's demonstrating a survival benefit in MDS MPN. And, you know,
most of these patients were CMML patients. So I want to talk a little bit about MEK inhibition.
So this is actually an IIT that I developed that's open at Huntsman, OHSU, and Fred Hutch.
So this is a trial, it's a phase two trial of cobimetinib, which is an oral MEK inhibitor as a
therapy, in patients with CMML who have RAS or MAP kinase-activating mutations
at a VAF of 5% or greater. So it's not just KRAS and NRAS, but it also includes
other sympathetic mutations that activate the RAS/MAP kinase signaling pathway.
And we have two cohorts, untreated CMML and CMML patients who have been HMA-exposed,
and we're giving them cobimetinib phase one through 21 of a 28-day cycle for up to a year.
So this was opened at Huntsman in 2021 and later at Fred Hutch and OHSU. We were able to enroll 14
patients. It was hard to accrue. We closed to accrual in December of 2025, so very recently
here. And that was primarily because Genentech is no longer manufacturing cobimetinib for use in
clinical studies. The primary endpoint is overall response rate by MDS MPN criteria. And we're seeing
50% response rate in the newly diagnosed cohort and about a 25% response rate in the HMA-exposed
cohort. Of course, these are small numbers. But we've also done single-cell RNA-seq of
longitudinal samples. We're currently analyzing this data and hoping to publish it later this
year. But I want to go on and talk about some other agents that are under active
investigation in CMML. So we actually use rexalitinib in CMML quite a bit. And
that's not because CMML is associated with JAK2 mutations, but it is because
CMML is explicitly sensitive to GM-CSF signaling, which you can block with JAK2 inhibition.
So JAK2 mutations actually only occur in 5% to 10% of CMML patients.
There was a phase one study of rex in CMML that enrolled 20 patients,
both untreated and HMA-exposed. Rexalitinib was pretty well tolerated, kind of the typical side
effect profiles that you might see in MPN. There were spleen responses, and there were some
hemologic improvements. There was not symptomatic improvement, although this was noted clinically,
and that might just have been because the pros were not appropriate for use in this population.
There was no association between response in any single cytokine level in patient plasma samples.
However, because there did seem to be clinical benefit, this is being studied in a phase two
clinical trial currently, with a phase two dose being 20 milligrams twice daily.
And so this was last reported on in ASH 2023. Notably, 70% of these patients had proliferative
CMML. And according to the MDS-MPN response criteria, 66% of patients actually did have
clinical benefit, and 30% of patients did have, you know, spleen volume reduction over
at least or over 35%. And we saw symptom improvement using the MPN-SAF-PSS score.
This has led to kind of interest in developing other JAK2 inhibitors in CMML. So there are two
new studies of procretinib in CMML. And procretinib may end up having greater efficacy because, as
you guys probably know, it's also a FLT3 inhibitor. It's an IRAC1 inhibitor. And it can also inhibit a
CBR1, so potentially improving anemia responses as well. So there's a phase one, two trial that's
open at Mount Sinai, looking at procretinib in combination with AZA. And then there's also this
phase two PROSPERA trial that's looking at procretinib in combination versus, sorry,
procretinib versus hydroxyurea. Lenzilumab is an antibody that neutralizes GMC-SF,
this has been studied in CMML as well in a phase one trial. It's dose IV. And, you know,
the overall response rate by MBS MPN criteria was only 27%. But there did seem to be a signal
in patients who had RAS pathway mutations. And so this kind of led to the PREACH-M phase two,
three trial in Australia, looking at AZA in combination with lenzilumab. And, you know, the
responses from this trial were actually pretty impressive in CMML. So there were 32 patients
enrolled on a len-AZA arm, and 86% of them achieved a CR or optimal marrow CR within the
first 12 months by the overlap criteria. So it's very hard to achieve, you know, CRs
using these criteria. So I'm curious to see this, the results when it's published, because
it's almost too good to believe. There was a high rate of decreases in mutational subclones
in the study as well, and it was well tolerated. Lastly, I wanted to talk a little bit about IO202,
which is an anti-LIL-RB4 monoclonal antibody. So, LIL-RB4 is an inhibitory checkpoint receptor
that's highly expressed on neoplastic monocytes, and importantly also on monocytic blast equivalents,
pro-monocytes and monoblasts. So this antibody depletes LIL-RB4 positive cells through antibody
dependent cytotoxicity and antibody dependent phagocytosis. It was investigated in CMML patients
in part 2b of the phase one trial that was actually done at MD Anderson with Dr. DiNardo
and in combination with azacitidine in 21 HMA-naive CMML patients.
The CR rate was around 30% and the overall response rate was nearly 70%. The reduction in
monocyte count was quite rapid. The medium time to response was one cycle, and it was fairly well
tolerated as well. And what was interesting here is that there were improved responses with higher
LIL-RB4 expression. There was also some pretty significant reductions in MPN-SAF symptom scores,
and this drug was efficacious seemingly in patients with ASXL1 mutations. And so about
70% of patients had ASXL1 mutations in this trial. And also of the three KRAS-mutated patients,
three of them actually cleared their KRAS mutations, which is pretty remarkable.
These are other ongoing CMML trials. So this is becoming more and more common,
so I think we're going to see more of this in the future, and hopefully we can
kind of improve outcomes for this porous leukemia going forward. Thank you.